Over the past 35 years, North Korea has developed
both nuclear weapons and missiles to deliver
them.
How did this happen?
The North Korea nuclear crisis dates back
to 1980, when a spy satellite detected nuclear
reactor construction north of Pyongyang.
In 1992, Secretary of State James Baker won
a Denuclearization Declaration in which both
Koreas foreswore the work to build a bomb.
Still, Pyongyang’s plutonium stocks surged.
Bill Clinton sought to keep North Korea in
the Non-Proliferation Treaty.
This culminated in the 1994 Agreed Framework.
Pyongyang agreed to abandon its bomb program
for reactors and fuel.
North Korea later admitted it began cheating
almost immediately.
Once again, America sought to assuage North
Korea with incentives.
Secretary of State Condoleezza Rice even lifted
sanctions.
Once again, the North cheated.
In 2006, it tested a nuclear bomb.
As for Obama, he ignored North Korea to focus
on Iran.
The problem is North Korea views diplomacy
less as a means to peace and more as a way
to buy time.
Diplomacy is not a religion to be worshipped
blindly nor a cost-free option.
Indeed, when it comes to Korea, its price
may one day be counted in millions
of lives.